the culinary union says it's workers and
their families are not safe from covet
19 they want everyone in a casino to be
required to wear masks not just workers
the i-team's Vanessa Murphy live in the
newsroom with the concerns of those
workers
yeah the culinary union has these photos
posted on its website they're trying to
avoid showing guests and customers faces
but what they want to show here is that
employees are wearing face coverings
they're required to but most guests and
customers are not now the union is
calling for face coverings required for
guests and customers and public areas
and mandatory kovat 19 testing of all
employees before returning to work and
then regular testing some gaming groups
like win and station casino say they're
already testing all employees before
they return to work the culinary union
represents housekeepers restaurant
workers dealers one concern is workers
on the front lines who catch the virus
may bring it home to their families
according to the Union since the start
of the pandemic 17 union members and
family members of union members have
died from the virus the total number of
union members who have been diagnosed
with the virus or hospitalized since
casinos reopened was not available but
here's what one casino worker said today
I have observed that guests are not
wearing masks and public spaces in
Treasure Island that concerns me because
I don't feel safe I do not want to bring
the COBIT 19 back to my family my
children my partner has a bad kidney and
a bad heart and we have to be extra
cautious now the culinary union is not
only asking casinos to make these
changes but they are calling on the
Clark County Commission governor Steve
Sicily and the Nevada Gaming Control
Board to mandate these changes and then
enforce them reporting live in the
newsroom
Vanessa Murphy 8 News now